Мені би хотілось нагазати цифри які
сьогодні оприлюднила Служба безпеки
України 68 затриманих попів і
митрополитів Московської церквию вони
всі займалися не тільки державною зрадою
але вони займалися торгівлею зброєю і
дитячою порнографією колеги в залі ви
підтримуєте торгівлю зброєю
розповсюдження дитячої порнографії то
чому на В нас немає зараз На порядку
денному законопроєктів про заборону
ліквідацію Московської церкви і
розірвання будь-яких контактів з Москвою
Московський пи наводили ракети на наші
міста і села московські попи роздають
зброю в церквах московським терористам
московські попи До сих пір відмовляються
відспівувати наших загиблих захисників
питання ви це все підтримуєте ви це все
толеруєте вам це все підходить якщо ні
то я прошу будь ласка підпишіться
терміново під скликанням позачергової
сесії під винесенням залу законопроектів
які ліквідовують Московську церкву